the other day new wig new hair come take
me out this moon glare
normani and cardi b are here to show you
their wild side
on friday normani dropped her new track
wild side featuring cardi b
along with the accompanying jaw-dropping
music video
and it is well wild
thank you i worked worked really hard
just check out the two superstars
dancing in the buff together and
absolutely slaying the whole damn thing
i'll be waiting on you with some laundry
down low like bombs
nothing but a robe in your house i wanna
put these pretty pink clothes in your
mouth send nudes to
the video is chock full of normani's
signature sleek dance moves
[Music]
and did i mention her dance moves
[Music]
normani opened up about working with
cardi on the project in a press release
saying she had already been in rehearsal
prepping for the music video for about
three weeks when the rapper heard the
song for the first time
quote she really showed up for me and
brought this record to life by simply
doing what cardi does
best i love that woman down and i'm
forever grateful
i feel like this is normani big comeback
and
like i want you guys to treat it like
it's her birthday like this is literally
her birthday and like this song this
everything is amazing and i'm just so
proud of her
uh i'm just like the the support team
i'm the support team okay i'm just here
like yay
but um i'm so excited you guys are gonna
see
like normani in a different
light oh my gosh i'm excited i
this is amazing of course this isn't the
first time the two have teamed up
back in 2020 normani made a cameo in
cardi's wap video
and absolutely crushed that choreo
as for wildside the track follows
normani's show-stopping single
motivation
normani performed her hit single at the
mtv video music awards in 2019.
i'm so excited no i'm proud of myself
and it was with her right after she
brought the house down
i am speechless that performance tell me
what went into it
people don't have any idea like it's
three minutes i'm up there on stage but
they have no slightest idea all the hard
work blood sweat tears
i literally have bruises on my knees
from however many times i did that split
um but
it really does take a village how are
you feeling right now this is a
life-changing moment for you
it's honestly a dream come true i've
worked incredibly hard you know
seven eight long years in preparation of
this moment
and it's just really beautiful because
it's also the beginning so i'm just
really really grateful for the
[Music]
opportunity
you